- Welcome back.
I love finding heartwarming stories
from the internet and
presenting them here.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music) (crowd cheering)
So I'm big into crafting.
I'm not great at it, but I'm big into it.
So this next story touches my heart.
I love it so much.
A North Carolina teen taught herself
to crochet in the pandemic
and it turned into a
thriving small business.
But it's her crochet jellyfish
that are particularly
notable. Here's why she
donates the jellyfish
to babies in the NICU.
The tentacles remind the babies
of their mother's umbilical chords
which is I know, see her face.
I know, it's so sweet.
So let's get her in here.
Say hi to Mindy J who watches
on WCCB Charlotte CW5.
What's up Mindy?
- I'm good. How are you?
- Awesome. Okay, so this
is the sweetest thing ever.
How did this come about?
- So I actually started
crocheting during the pandemic
as a way to kind of get off of my phone.
And my mama does hair,
so she had a pediatrician
in her chair at her salon
and she had saw this idea
on Facebook where people
were crocheting jellyfish
for babies in the NICU, and it's a way
for them to kind of calm down de-stress
and it makes their lives
a little bit easier.
So she thought
that this would be a
great community service
outreach project for me and
I thought it would be too.
So I started doing it.
- Oh my gosh, I just really
want you to keep talking.
Like your accent is
maybe my favorite accent
that's ever been on this show.
My gosh, you are so cute.
How many have you made?
- So I've made 65 so far
and each one takes me
about an hour to an
hour and a half to make.
And this project is super important
to me cause even though I
wasn't in the NICU as a baby
I've seen how stressful it is
for the families who do
have babies in the NICU.
And I wanna help them in
like any way that I can.
And one of the great
things that has came out
of this project is that I've
had so many people message me
and like ask me how I made these
so that they could do it
for their community too.
- Oh my gosh, I love you so much.
Justin just handed me these.
They are so cute.
And I'm totally taking these
to my little cause
they're gonna love these.
These are so cute.
It's such a special thing
you're doing for people too
at a hard time for families.
So you have such a great heart.
So does your mama.
Thank you so much Mindy J I'm
liking your post right now.
Right. (crowd cheering)
(notification ding)
- Thank you.
- And that's not all our season long.
Partner pilot pin makers of G2
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Want to support your continued efforts
of making these jellyfish
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars to
help you out. (crowd cheering)
Thank you so much and thank
you to all our guest today,
Selena Gomez, Chef Ming
Tsai, AJ Jefferson,
Michael Najee Harris,
Kelly Sasso, Elena Laguta
and all of our friends
at WTAE 4 in Pittsburgh.
You'll have a great day.
And if it's not try and change it.